schmuck gefällter wwf 50 euro radames
luca und meine damen hilfsbereite sind
eingeblendet ich habe hier auf der
plattform mit einigen durfte bestellt
die wirklich kostenlos sind
man zahlt quasi keinen preis für das
produkt sondern wirklich nur für den
versand das heißt diese ganzen produkte
die ich mir bestellt habe sind 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 8 9 10 produkte habe ich mir
bestellt die sind alle die kosten so
nichts da ist schmuck bei das sind
sachen bei verschiedene dinge solche
videos gab es schon vor monaten die
sache ist dass ich glaube dass die
meisten dieser videos wirklich einfach
gefällt verantwortlich habe auf diese
produkte monate lang gewartet die kamen
alle einzeln haben ich habe die adressen
ja alles abgeklebt das sind aber alles
durch chinesische adressen gewesen und
stelle ich einfach vor ich bestelle
meinen eltern nach hause und sage den ok
bald kommt ein paket aussichten da
irgendwann ein paar wochen und dann
kommen monatelang immer so alle paar
wochen kommt und als paket im
briefkasten da kommt so ein kleines und
keines alles einzeln verschickt ihnen
wie soll die scheiße eigentlich was wir
heute allerdings machen werde ist ich
werde das mit euch alles auspacken
von daher fangen wir da jetzt
tatsächlich auch mal ein bisschen
[Applaus]
produktnummer der uno der heirat story
ist sondern was drin in der märkte
direkt hat das aus china kommen packe
ich hier aus überall styroporkügelchen
ich wollte dass sie jetzt versuchten
kostet wirklich null euro diese probleme
sind die leute aus hannover muss ich
ehrlich gesagt zu geben dafür dass die
neue leute man kann sich einfach nicht
gesperrt die produkte jesus produzenten
0 euro gekürzt sind egal was ich sage
alter ist es ist einfach den preiswerten
euro diese brille meine damen und herren
herz weil produkt was auch angekommen
ist ist wie sage ich ja noch eine brille
stellt tatsächlich noch eine brille ich
weiß nicht warum ich die bestellt haben
also es ist wirklich schon monatelang
ach du scheiße die hat sogar eine stärke
weil ja in den leuten sitzen da kann man
so batterien rheinpark nur so ist so ein
schalter ich und hier sind hier ist die
pflegesparte okay ich meine leute was
will man erwarten wenn 0 euro aber gut
die beiden ersten produkte die ich also
bestellt haben wir zu hause sind brillen
kommen wir direkt zum nächsten produkt
ist
ich hoffe die gedanken wieder hoch wie
wir diese scheiß eigentlich bestellt hat
ja es geht nicht an aber da sind auch
irgendwie kleine batterien so wirklich
drin deswegen habe ich mir tatsächlich
gestellt weil ich dachte okay das ist
total schade das hätte die quasi an ihm
dran hier oben sieht man hier schon und
dann leuchtet das eigentlich aber
funktioniert nicht wirklich beschweren
kann ich mich da normalerweise eher
weniger ist auf jeden fall das wird ein
produkt was ich mich gestellt habe von
den zehn produkten freunde das nächste
produkt würde ich sagen machen aber
direkt weiter ist ach du scheiße schmuck
gefällter visier 50 euro also dass hier
wirklich leute ihr müsst euch immer noch
überlegen das kostet wirklich nur euro
da denke ich mir halt bieten überall
also knoten drin
wir werden nachdem ein komplettes outfit
mit allen sachen die zusammenstellen
nicht mehr gestellt habe ich weiß
allerdings nicht mehr ob man überhaupt
machen kann haben wir manchmal ein wenig
weiter mit dem nächsten produkt das ist
das denn also es geht eigentlich
aussehen langsamer das stift hier so
sieht es aus aber es ist ein laser laser
pointer für 0 euro auf der pulli sieht
man ja man sieht ja was ist 100 als gut
wenn ich ganz ehrlich bin habe ich mich
auch noch ein bild anhalter arschloch
nächstes produktes was ich mir bestellt
habe ist echt ich glaube ich eine uhr
yahoo das ist halt das war als das ist
dabei seine elektro über 12 14 ist schon
eins oder so und dann hat man schon bis
zu ziehen so hält einfach nicht null
euro weg sport meine damen und herren
machen längst verschoben und als hope
you work out produkten ein verkauf ich
hoffe den socken drauf es ist das video
nicht mit family friends dafür ist auf
jeden fall das richtige produkt freude
haben wir immer von allerdings direkt
weiter mit dem diesen taschenmesser
alter das weiß ich gar nicht mehr es ist
wirklich einfach so sondern seine
kreditkarten größe da kannst es hier so
irgendwie hinter klemmen leute so dann
kannst du dir ins portemonnaie packen
und dann machst du halt so dann kommt
2018 besser als die pistole und haben
wir hier die statischen muss meine damen
und herren wieder glaube ich eine kette
oder ein lederarmband sie gar nicht mehr
so scheiße aus also ich würde es nicht
tragen aber es sieht jetzt halt echt
nicht nach neurologisch bestellungen aus
oder so kommen zum letzten produkt das
ich gestellt habe das jetzt es soll
glaub ich so ein frauen leid sein ich
zeige euch jetzt aber ein finales outfit
[Musik]
meine damen und herren herzlich
willkommen zumal ein outfit 0 euro das
ganze gekostet die sich schon hier oben
bei der händler sie sich schon hier
meine brille die leuchten kann dass sie
kann eigentlich auch leute nämlich keine
batterien switchen jemanden der bund
unfassbar geiles abgaben die sich hier
meine digital smart watch dann seht ihr
hier meine krasse goldkette ich jetzt
meine laser mit dem kann ich mich
anfreunden und hier ist mein motto
[Musik]